North Korea has testified a ballistic
missile office eastern coast it comes as
its leader is in Russia for talks with
President Vladimir Putin they're
expected to meet in the coming hours the
whole discussions at a Space Center in
Russia's Far East the U.S suspects Kim
Jong-un is ready to supply weapons to
Moscow for the war in Ukraine Washington
has warned that any arms deal with North
Korea would violate U.N sanctions
of Florence Louis monitoring
developments for us now from Seoul so
where Florence North Korea has launched
a ballistic missile test as we've heard
is there significance in the timing of
that
yes Carrie in fact we're getting reports
from Japanese media that it could have
been as many as two missiles launched by
North Korea now it's banned by un from
launching missile tests and yet North
Korea has conducted a record number of
weapons tests this year now this coming
ahead of a an expected meeting between
Kim and Putin on Wednesday I think
perhaps we could take it as an
indication or as North Korea attempting
to send a signal perhaps that it has no
intention of complying with un sanctions
now as for the meeting itself Japanese
media are reporting that it will take
place at a cosmodrome this would not
only be a highly secure location but
also a highly um well highly symbolic
venue
um especially if the two countries are
going to be cooperating in the Aerospace
industry in the Aerospace fields we know
North Korea covers satellite technology
it wants to launch a spy satellite into
space now North Korean State media has
given a lot of media coverage to this
trip and I think it indicates the high
value North Korea places on this visit
and also perhaps a certain level of
confidence that this upcoming Kim Putin
meeting is going to go well now Kim
himself has said that his visit is proof
of North Korea prioritizing it its ties
with Russia so far he's already met the
Russian minister of natural resources
and also an official for in charge of
North Korea's economy was there so
that's an indication that trade is also
going to be important North Korea
perhaps could be negotiating sending
laborers to Russia that would be that
would give it much needed hard currency
so we've heard from U.S officials that
an arms deal could be on the cards but
now we're getting clearer indications of
what North Korea could be wanting in
return
and what has the international reaction
been then to this upcoming Kim Putin
meeting
well we've heard U.S officials renew
their warnings saying even that they
won't hesitate to impose new sanctions
if an arms deal with Korea and with
North Korea and Russia goes ahead and in
fact we're hearing from that the U.S
Deputy Commerce Secretary who's due to
arrive in Seoul next year says he's
going to be holding talks on how to
strengthen export controls to ensure
that Russia doesn't get the equipment
and the material it needs for to use in
its war on Russia now regionally we've
heard South Korean and Japanese
government say they're monitoring
developments in Russia very closely
we've also heard the South Korean
president urge China as a permanent
member of the U.N security Council to do
more to rein in the threat the nuclear
threat from North Korea but he also said
that South Korea will draw closer to
Japan and the U.S
as a means to counter Pyongyang now we
know China is a strong Ally of North
Korea and Russia it is also the biggest
trade partner so it has a lot of
Leverage and some analysts believe that
it is it would be key in preventing an
arms deal from going ahead now so far
China's foreign Ministry has only said
about Kim's visit to North to Russia
that this is a matter between two
Nations but some Chinese analysts say
that you know China China views this as
a reaction to the US's actions in this
region and China has made no secret of
the fact that it wants to challenge the
international order something that and
this is a view that North Korea and
Russia share okay Florence Louis thank
you for that
let's stay with us though and bring in
that John Park he's director of the
career project at Harvard Kennedy
schools Belfast Center he joins us from
Cambridge Massachusetts welcome to the
program uh put simply then in Practical
terms what will both Russia and North
Korea be hoping to get out of this
meeting between Putin and Kim
okay it's a troubling development
because if you look at it it's almost
like a problem-solving type of
partnership each leader is going to be
able to get very specialized problem
solving capabilities from the other for
Putin clearly it's access to these
Munitions that he needs in his War of
Attrition in Ukraine and for Kim you're
looking at a situation where he's tried
space launch vehicle tests twice now and
has failed the most recent one we'll see
what all the specifications are in terms
of what just took place but with respect
to his effort to put a military
satellite into orbit this is something
where Russia can uniquely help him and
we saw that in terms of Russia helping
Iran put their kayam satellite into
orbit in August of 2022 so all the
pieces are there to help each other when
it comes to these two leaders with
unique problem-solving capabilities and
interestingly what might China make of
this then they have separate bilateral
relations with both Russia and North
Korea don't they
chair and Carrie this is where apply
history is really important if you look
at the relationship that China has
developed cultivated with Russia and its
relationship with North Korea those are
really transactional relationships
they're ones where in certain instances
there's been exploitation if you look at
these long duration deals for natural
resources on the energy side with Russia
China was underpaying them and with
respect to the cold trade with North
Korea a similar to the situation in the
second half of the 2000s however the
relationship between Russia and North
Korea is definitely uh you know bumps in
the road ups and downs but there is an
affinity that the two of them have and
right now in this dire situation it
looks like a type of partnership where
they're trying to help each other out
that definitely doesn't exist in the
respective by a lot of relationship with
China and to what extent will North
Korea see this face-to-face meeting as a
way of boosting its perceived standing
on the international Arena
well there's there's a lot of fanfare
between the two countries if you look at
the greeting and the ceremony and all of
the red carpet type of treatment that
Kim received when he arrived in Russia
it gives you a sense how both countries
are elevating their leaders in that
respect and really is a message to their
domestic populations if anything the
secondary message is to the
International Community so if you look
at this type of dynamic it looks like
things are going well between the team
leaders and through this partnership
things will improve better as well so
that's the dynamic and that's the
messaging but definitely to their
respective domestic audiences during
very difficult times and given what you
say watching on where does this leave
the U.S and South Korea for example
very difficult if you look at it the
primary deterrence messages if North
Korea proceeds with this Munitions deal
with Russia there'll be more sanctions
but if you look at it both North Korea
and Russia are the subject of the most
intense U.S sanctions in the case of
Russia their sectoral sanctions in their
energy sector in the case of North Korea
long-standing sanctions but in the case
of North Korea one thing that we have to
look in more detail is that there's this
natural experiment that took place North
Korea since January of 2020 imposed its
own quarantine it sealed off its own
border and so if you think of the level
of difficulties and hardships that ensue
from that they far exceed anything that
sanctions can do so at this particular
point in time with the two leaders about
to meet I do think the sanctions warning
component has really run its course in
this particular instance John part we
very much appreciate your insights thank
you
thank you